what is your strategy to visit brother
canada
my strategy to win big brother canada is
to go in the house play both sides use
my social game to really manipulate
people
charm people and reel em in a little
i'd like to create a final four alliance
with those that i trust most and then
yeah use a guy if i have to a big strong
man to win cops for me in the beginning
of the game so i don't have to get blood
on my hands and
then when it's time to start winning
physical comps show off my athletic side
what kind of personality will you clash
with the most in the house
i definitely don't get along with people
who take life too seriously i physically
i just can't it's like why what what's
going on right now like just relax and i
just take it easy so people that are
walking around super stern and in your
face it's going to be a lot for me to
deal with and i don't like that
that
showman's our nomads
showmance if it presents itself i'm not
turning anything down i know sometimes
it can be detrimental to your game but
who am i to say no to
big brother cupid if if he so happens to
be in the house you know you'd be better
than bachelor yeah
oh this to go ahead you do bachelor they
always break up
swerve
gonna root for me because i'm going to
bring the perfect blend of drama
entertainment and drive to win this game
i'm willing to go out there backstab
manipulate cheat do whatever i have to
do to win the game okay